cela fait 22 ans que nous avons commencé cette
saga, comment avons-nous eu autant de chance d'arriver si
loin,
cette famille est prête à se
réunir, c'est un rêve devenu réalité, je veux dire,
c'est définitivement une liste de choses à faire, c'est sûr, oh
nous sommes au sommet de sa franchise.  vite
le cœur et l'âme de la franchise Fast and
Furious sur le
terrain, plus nous faisons de films, plus ils deviennent
gros, nous pouvons vous surpasser
parce que nous le devons à nos fans,
l'énormité de tout vous frappe comme
une main droite de  la mâchoire que tu sais encore
conduire à chaque fois que je suis sur le plateau, je
dois me pincer,
je les harcèle juste pour qu'ils
participent, c'est un tel honneur
de faire partie de cette famille, c'est le
problème d'avoir une si grande famille,
comment  choisissez-vous ceux que vous sauvez si
chanceux aujourd'hui,
le football et vous tous